welcome to part three of the dev byte
series making apps beautiful I'm Ankur
Kotwal thus far we've been focused on
making our list reader app beautiful on
phones but we haven't really looked at
the tablet side of things so let's see
if we just take that app that we've been
using so far and and put it on a tablet
let's see what it looks like so we have
a nexus 10 here with the app running and
you'll see it's not particularly
attractive at all there's all this
wasted white space on the right hand
side and then when I go into the detail
view the text is going edge to edge sure
the fonts are nice and we've we've
modernized it with an action bar but
this isn't a great tablet experience so
let's switch back to the slides
let's talk about what we can do and
really the obvious thing to do in this
situation is to implement a two-pane UI
so we're going to go from something like
what you see here to something like this
where we have both the list items on the
left hand side and the detailed items on
the right hand side the way we're going
to do that is we're going to try and
basically keep or reuse as much as the
code as possible we don't want to write
a phone version and a tablet version of
the apps that's not how you build
Android apps so we're going to use a
little trick that we called XML
references so let's look at the code on
on on my machine here we we have our two
activities the the the list activity and
the detail activity well you'll notice
we've also got a layout here for a to
paint activity now one way to load this
is that when we load the initial
activity the list activity we could just
at that point work out whether we're a
tablet or not and load the two pane
layout we're not going to do that we're
going to use this nice references this
XML references trick but I particularly
like so we're still going to load
activity article list as our as our
layout but we're going to specify this
Refs XML file and that name isn't
special we're just calling it that
but what is special is we're going to
chuck it in a directory called values
smallest with 600 dip land the smallest
with 600 it basically tells us that this
is a tablet that's a metric that we use
the land tells us we're in landscape
mode so in landscape mode on a tablet
we're going to load this ref store XML
and this this file has the activity
article list and what we're saying is if
you refer to a layout called activity
article list instead of returning what's
already there in your resource folder
return a different layout so load whoops
load this layout here activity article -
pane so again we've done it all in XML
without actually having to change any
Java and we'll get the right layout
we'll get the - pane layout which is
great but we're not done yet because we
actually need to make one more change
which is when the user selects and item
from that ListView
we shouldn't launch another activity
into their detailed view what we should
be doing is selecting or replacing that
that right-hand fragment so what we're
going to do is actually in our activity
in our article list activity we're going
to work out if we're in - pane mode
there's multiple ways you can do this so
we're not going to to go into it in a
great amount of detail but once you know
if you if you're working in in two pane
mode all you're doing is basically when
the item is the list item is selected
you're going to get your fragment
manager and replace that that detail
fragment with the relevant one if you're
in single pane mode you're just going to
go and call the start activity so on
phones will start a new activity on
tablets will just replace that fragment
on the right hand side simple as that we
have our two pane UI of course this is
all based on the assumption that you are
already using fragments if you're not
using fragments in your app already I
think you're making a mistake
it's it's really important that you do
so it allows you to to make these apps
really flexible depending on the form
factor and you'll see we did it with
minimal effort so let's switch back to
to our our slides and what we'll see now
we've got our nice two-pane UI great
but one thing that's still lacking here
is spacing that those margins that we
specified on either side for the
detailed view they don't seem as
applicable for a tablet and in fact even
now ListView seems a little bit squashed
more so than it should be so what we're
going to do is actually we're going to
go and override some of those values for
tablets so switching back to the code
you'll recall that we had dimensions XML
file that we'd specified for our list
views we'd had some top and bottom
margins and for our detailed view we had
some margins on on either side what
we're going to do is specify another
dimensions file for tablets 6 600 dip
and we don't care whether it's portrait
or landscape we're going to use these
dimensions and instead of 8 and 16 we're
going to go 16 dips vertically for
margin for the ListView and 80 dips on
either side so now let's switch back to
slides and see what that will actually
end up achieving this is what we have
now when we put those new margins in
we've got much better spacing vertically
between our list items on the left and
on either side in the detailed view as
well so with that being said we've now
come to the end of this check point
which is this is where we started with
our tablet app not very attractive at
all and this is where we've come to so
the next part we're going to focus on
performance tuning